now the other nice thing about this
number is that if ever
a thief
finds
a briefcase with a lock on it belonging
to a physicist the first number he
should try to unpick that briefcase is
just type in 137 because it's the sort
of number that comes into the head of so
many physicists
beautiful number i think can i ask you a
personal question yeah is it the
combination to your briefcase i don't
have a lock on my briefcase
nobody would find anything useful in it
anyway
it's such a mess
well i thought it would be nice to talk
about the so-called fine structure
constant
this is widely used in atomic physics
when we're trying to understand the
motion of electrons around atoms and the
nature of the very small splittings
between the sharp lines in the in the
spectra of atoms
but what i like about alpha is that it
combines
three fundamental constants in a in a
rather beautiful way
so it's this is called the fine
structure
constant
and so it's given by e squared e is the
charge of the electron
over
h bar
times c so here's h bar that's planck's
constant divided by 2 pi and here c is
the speed of light and that number is we
describe that number as dimensionless
it's not in centimeters or seconds it's
just a plain beautiful number and its
value is 1 over 137
to a very good approximation and i think
the fact that this this number is
independent of units it makes it a it
makes it a very fundamental number in
science and one in which as well that if
you
decide to want to get in touch with some
aliens on on some distant planet
uh going around
orbiting around a star perhaps a bit
like our own sun
it would be one of the numbers you would
signal to these aliens if you if to
indicate that we have a scientific and
technologically capable civilization on
this planet so for example it wouldn't
be much use if you communicated with
them and said look i weighed eight
eighty kilograms and my height is one
what one meter eighty these numbers
wouldn't mean anything to them what
would mean something to them is the
value of this fine structure constant
alpha because they would have they would
know that number as well if they have ma
if they've made telescopes and have got
electronic equipment and are sending out
radio waves and so on they will know
that number for sure there are a couple
of other numbers as well that you could
send them one would be for example the
ratio of the mass of the proton to the
electron and that's something like 1
840. so if you send numbers
like 1 over 137 or indeed perhaps more
conveniently just
137
or 1840
it would then the alien civilization
would say right these people understand
science and technology uh understand
quantum mechanics so it'd be a really
nice number to send out to them
oh yes this this is a to me this is a
very interesting number and i bought my
colleagues in the in particle cosmology
and particle physicists and so on about
this number i've a few zany ideas about
it but i won't go into those at the
moment they take too long but it's been
it's been a topic of great interest i
mean you will find
very learned text on the magic of alpha
it's a magical number i mean feynman for
example
in his classical those three classic
textbooks he wrote for for for the
undergraduate courses at uh
at caltech um i can't quote from him
directly but he felt that this was a
number you know that was that all
physicists are very very deeply attached
to and almost has a magic to it because
you there's no theory that explains why
it has the value it has i mean this is
the mystery of it is just this value
but you can be sure that if the value a
little bit different
from the value it actually has we
wouldn't be around here talking about it
now
you know atomic physics is is
relies
is the way it is because of the value of
alpha and
you know in universes you could
cosmologists are now talking about
universes in which alpha could be
different in which these three constants
the makeup alpha could be different and
um you know then physics
chemistry biochemistry would be totally
different and we might not be around to
talk about it so the value of alpha is
very very special but we still don't
know why it has the value it has
um well i probably don't speak that much
to lay people you're the first one i've
spoken to for a long time most of my
work involves teaching
undergraduates and working with my
colleagues on research and going to
conferences
um so
uh it's i think it's a little
perhaps a little bit resistant for uh
for for
i mean it actually isn't that
complicated i think it's very
fascinating so i'm glad to talk to you
about it today maybe it'll get a bit
better known